[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans son caddie
les 7h18 sur martinique la première ni
case monrose bonjour bonjour bonjour à
vous inscrire vous êtes le maire de
sainte-luce ces derniers jours
aujourd'hui du mois pour encore souhaité
les bons voeux de la nouvelle année donc
voir twitter veut c'est moi aussi je
vous présente mes voeux pour cette année
ainsi qu'à tous ceux qui nous font
l'honneur et le plaisir de nous écouter
ce matin il est de tradition que
jusqu'au 31 janvier on peut encore
présenté les voeux ce que je fais
volontiers voilà les quinze monrose
qu'est-ce qui s'annonce de saillant de
prometteur justement pour cette année
2010 8 pour la ville de sainte luce dont
vous êtes le maire alors de prométhée un
oui nous allons continuer la mise en
place de notre projet en 2018 je crois
que 2017 a été une année où nous avons
déployé un certain nombre de projets sur
lesquels nous étions engagés auprès de
la population bon il ya des choses qui
se voit tel que les travaux que nous
avons réalisés dans les entrées de bourg
notamment
mais il ya aussi ceux qui ne se voit pas
et que ceux qui nous mobilise énormément
par exemple la vision du pmu qui est en
cours la réorganisation l'écriture dense
et puis nous avons passé aussi cette
année beaucoup de temps à préparer à
préparer 2018 alors 2018
est-ce que c'est l'année qui verra enfin
l'achèvement des travaux de la fameuse
médiathèque qui est devenu une sorte de
gouffre financier cette affaire quand
même d'un coût initial de 4 millions 4
je crois on a actuellement près du
double 1 pas loin d'eux peut-être de 9
millions avec des travaux toujours en
cours alors que la livraison initiale
était pour
l'année 2011 peut-être fin 2011 mais
enfin voilà un chantier qui traîne et
qui coûte on a l'impression de plus en
plus cher alors gouffre financier non ce
n'est pas un gouffre financier que le
coup a doublé comme le coup à le co a
presque doublé
marion qu'à l'origine c'était prévu pour
4 millions 3 environ nous en sommes à
peu près aussi un peu plus de 6 millions
bien mais s'agit pas du gouffre
financier d'ailleurs je précise bien que
les les retards pris dans les travaux de
la médiathèque ne sont pas dus à des
problèmes financiers
la commune de sainte luce a toujours
honoré ses factures présentées par des
entreprises le retard pris effectivement
sont un chantier commencé en 2010 ce qui
a été décidé en 2006 d'ailleurs un par
un ancien conseiller municipal commence
en 2010 toujours pas achevé à cause de
difficultés de réalisation d'une part la
coordination du chantier par le maître
de lui-même
et puis par l'exécution des lots par les
entreprises il faut dire que c'est un
chantier difficile à réaliser de part
son site mais aussi par son architecture
on a perdu du temps on a dû à plusieurs
reprises ou à lancer des marché parce
que les entreprises étaient défaillantes
on a résilié sur 15 euros on a dû
résilier une dizaine de contrats pascal
et contrat qui avait été passé à
plusieurs reprises parce qu'à chaque
fois il ya des entreprises défaillantes
et c'est pour ça qu'on a pris du retard
c'est pas parce que c'est un gouffre
financier ça n'en est pas il sera achevé
cette année
il faut que ça soit achevé c'est à dire
que nous avons le le chantier le
bâtiment je précise le bâtiment hors
d'eau hors d'air sera achevé en passe
d'être achevée si vous passez à
sainte-luce vous verrez ce sens que ce
sentier ressemble actuellement à une
chili a beaucoup d'entreprises il ya
beaucoup d'ouvriers parce que nous avons
pu
moti voix motiver tout le monde et nous
devons achever ce bâtiment là le mois
dans le mois qui vient
après il va il va falloir l'aménager et
alors donc l'ouverture donc achevée mais
livraison peut être pas forcément 2018
c'est ce que c'est vraiment achevée
livrer maintenant après il faut
l'aménager parce que il faut rappeler
que dans ce bâtiment qui s'appelle
jusqu'à maintenant la médiathèque
il y à une salle de spectacle quoi
jusqu'à maintenant que ça va changer de
nom
je sais pas si nous allons nous
concerter avec lui c'est à ce niveau là
il y à une salle de spectacle il y à une
bibliothèque il y à une médiathèque pour
le multimédia il ya pas mal de choses là
dedans
donc il faudra ménager et ça ça ne
pourrait le prendre à une bonne année
autres dossiers pendants en ce début
d'année 2010 8 celui de l'assainissement
des eaux usées pour la zone
rivière-pilote sainte-luce alors sainte
luce qui se trouve donc en contrebas en
quelque sorte de rivière pilote qui
reçoit une partie des eaux usées de
rivière pilote
alors bon il ya un projet pour
l'assainissement des eaux usées à peu
près 20 millions là je crois c est oui
et vous vous opposez toujours à une
mutualisation des moyens avec notamment
la commune voisine
rivière pilote toujours au blocage comme
impression de 5,6 et il n'y a pas eu
on s'oppose par la mutualisation la la
communauté du cn dans sa très grande
majorité s'est opposé au projet par la
mutualisation ces deux sources
différentes nous faisons partie de
l'intercommunalité et précédemment donc
du sexe du syndicat des eaux du sud qui
était à l'époque responsable du
traitement des eaux usées et qui
maintenant traitement des eaux usées a
été transféré à l'espace sud donc la
communauté de communes
mais ce à quoi nous nous sommes opposés
c'est le projet qui nous semblait qui
nous semblait inadéquate inadaptée
pourquoi pour plusieurs raisons
déjà parce que il s'agissait de tirer
trois kilomètres de tuyauterie entre
sainte luce et rivière pilote
il s'agissait d'un projet de 20 millions
alors qu'on sait très bien parce que ça
a été fait ailleurs que si on installait
une station de traitement pouilly vient
pilote ça coûterait deux fois moins cher
il s'agit d'un aussi de dire que à
sainte luce on installe une station
d'épuration pour traiter 26000
équivalents habitants dans une zone
touristique et qu'il y avait là une
écurie n accueillera ensuite de dire que
l'émissaire en mer la tuyauterie de
rejet en mer des eaux même traité mais
pas parfaitement traitée évidemment
puisqu'il s'agit à la station
d'épuration le rejet en mer est posé sur
le corail est que ce corps est en train
de mourir et qu'il fallait pas comme ça
balançait des eaux douces d'olmes et à
pour ne pas risquer d'abîmer encore plus
le coin qui lui-même protège le rivage
des accusés où ça qu'on s'est opposé
principal je précise on ne se pose pas
la mutualisation
on sait aussi sur le fait sur le fond
celle du budget a même contenu du
programme at il des choses est ce que
les choses n'ont plus pour l'as que les
choses vont selon vous pouvoir évoluer
cette année
ou du point de vue de votre état
d'esprit où en êtes vous êtes toujours
dans cette opposition notre bien marquer
frontaliers qui kiffent constitue
finalement une forme de blocage dans
dans l'issue de ce dossier
ou est-ce que les choses vont peuvent
évoluer favorablement malgré la position
répétée réitéré roja bâché par pas par
l'ancien conseil municipal ancien maire
et nous le nouvel le nouveau conseil
municipal malgré les observations de la
population de sainte luce le 6 marie la
responsabilité de réaliser ce projet
nous verrons dans l'avenir les
conséquences nous verrons ce que ça aura
comme conséquence nous sommes certains
malheureusement ce ne sera pas une bonne
chose mais pour le littoral n'est pour
le site de sainte luce maintenant ça a
été réalisée c'est-à-dire que les la
tuyauterie a été réalisée tous les
travaux ont été réalisés
maintenant il y a autre chose si maire
de la commune de sainte luce nous ne
pouvons pas discuter de raccorder les
eaux usées de rivière-pilote même si on
nous parle de mutualisation si dans le
même temps au pied de la station
d'épuration qui devra être traitée un
équivalent de 26 mille habitants
notamment récupérer les eaux usées de
rivière pilote il y à des
dysfonctionnements il y a des cas ce qui
entraîne dans les rues de sainte luce
des remontées d'odeurs et de matières
fécales ce n'est pas possible
d'envisager les choses de cette manière
là
donc nous disons clairement qu'il faut
réparer nous avons dû ce qui me c'est
maintenant l'espace ce qui est
responsable de ce sujet là nous avons dû
émettre des ddd couillet à l'encontre du
président exposé sud qui nous semblait
vouloir lui faire du chantage
vous signez vouloir demander aux pelotes
et aurait passé tous nous on leur a dit
c'est votre responsabilité au niveau
sanitaire de faire en sorte que les et
la canonisation dont vous êtes
responsable c'est pas la commune qui
responsable des canalisations des eaux
usées soient réparés et sa pouvoir nous
permettre d'ouvrir des discussions
concernant
le raccordement de leur pilote affaire à
suivre on voit bien que les relations
avec l'espace sud et notamment le
président gène larcher sont parfois
conflictuelles un autre sujet de
crispation avec la communauté
d'agglomération espace sud le transfert
de compétences de la compétence tourisme
justement à cet espace sud comme comme
les autres communautés d'agglomération
dans la cacem que cap nord alors là vous
n'êtes pas content non plus vous vous
opposez même à l'état à l'application de
la loi en quelque sorte enfin jusqu'à
interdire même des les représentants de
la ville de sainte luce à la communauté
de l'espace sud de siéger au nouvel
office de tourisme intercommunal
non attendez non la fin c'est ce qu'on a
c'est ce qu'on a eu comme comme écho
quand même un venant de sainte luce nom
de cette religion certainement de je ne
sais pas d'où naît alors écoutez non
monsieur larcher s'est pas là on a peu
de temps donc il faut vaincre
synthétiser la wii mais c'est par avocat
sens et c'est l'orientation prise par le
comité de l'espace sud qui que nous
contestons nous faisons de la politique
par conviction
nous ne faisons pas ça pour être bien
avec untel ou avec une telle ou pour
l'avenir nous préparer un avenir
politique c'est pas ça nous faisons nous
le faisons par conviction et la
conviction que nous avons c'est que ce
qui a été décidé
il la loi ne dit par ailleurs
contrairement à ce qu on fait quoi ce
qui a été décidé n'est pas une bonne
chose là non plus comme nous pensons que
ces peines motion dont le dit pourquoi
parce que comment penser qu'une
structure administrative vient de la
gérer au mieux le tourisme que les
acteurs de terrain nous ne croyons pas
ça c'est la loi qui n'ont la loi dit pas
si le dis parce que moment la loi dit
quoi que les et si vous m'accordez un
peu de temps la loi dit quoi que les
intercommunalités en france en général
récupère la promotion l'orientation
l'information mais la loi ne dit pas que
les intercommunalités
la version wii la loi ne dit pas non
plus que les intercommunalités sont
obligés de récupérer la taxe de séjour à
sainte lucie 120000 euros dans notre
budget
la loi ne dit pas ça c'est l'espace sud
qui ont organisé les choses tout ça soit
comme ça nous ne sommes pas d'accord
nous le disons c'est pas parce que nous
nous n'aimons pas telle ou telle c'est
que nous ne sommes pas d'accord une lex
migros et pour conclure monsieur le
maire de sainte-luce nekkaz monrose
etes-vous en froid avec votre première
adjointe
il semble là aussi selon quelques échos
que nous avons pu recueillir du côté de
cette plus qu'elle ne siège plus au
conseil municipal depuis quelques temps
quand il s'agit de madame gladys jacquin
la première adjointe
oui tout à fait vous avez été absent oui
non mais c'est clair et là elle n'a pas
souvent été là depuis du six bons mois
alors que nous avons fait une mise au
point avec elle sur sa solidarité par
rapport au conseil municipal a décidé de
démissionner nous respectons sa décision
elle a démissioné lanaudoise idée de
l'aubaine nous respectons sa décision et
elle a été sa décision l'important pour
nous c'est de de faire le réaliser le
projet que nous sur lequel nous sommes
engagés devant la population de sainte
luce merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions ni case monrose bonne journée
assis à vous
[Musique]